welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars a rise of Skywalker
looked at number of mysteries unresolved
that haunted us nerds and our Restless
holiday slumber chief among them what
secret was then going to tell Wegg
well it turns out we now know for sure
what bins secret was but that answer
opens up a lot more mysteries about
things we missed all the way back in the
force awakens about Palpatine's true
agenda about the origin of the first
order and about how this all could tie
into the Mandalorian in the future of
the Star Wars universe more than warning
before I go any further and ruin your
life for the first time in 2020 okay so
we're referring of course to the moment
the heroes sunk into the quicksand
Upasana
finn screamed gray gray I never told you
that's my impression of eating sand then
below in the cave ray asks Finn what he
was going to tell her and he says I'll
tell you later he never does actor John
boyega shot down the theory that Finn
was going to tell ray that he loves her
instead according to an attendee at a
Q&A with director JJ Abrams JJ confirmed
that Ben was going to tell ray that he
is force-sensitive the attendee
clarified that JJ didn't announce this
to everyone during the Q&A but was asked
this question by a fan during the
one-on-one meeting greets and then
confirmed it
Wow those of us who attend fan q and A's
aren't always most trustworthy or the
most showered Finn's force sensitivity
is no secret throughout the events of
the rise of Skywalker in the final
battle on EXA call he somehow knows that
the final order navigation signal has
shifted from the deactivated tower up to
the one particular Star Destroyer that
they happened to be looking at because
of what he describes as a feeling which
is a screenwriting lingo for the script
just needs me to know this right now
later the moment Rey collapses after
destroying Palpatine her life force
seemingly depleted Finn stops dead in
his tracks on a falcon and senses her
Paul whispering to himself no Rey
similar to Leia since scene Hans death
in the force awakens obi-wan since scene
Alderaan's destruction and Yoda
since him Anakin killing all those kids
indeed Finn telling Rey in the cave that
he would tell her later echos the moment
Return of the Jedi when Luke teased Leia
about her own hidden force abilities
what is
asked me you canceled there have also
been unconfirmed reports of an alternate
director's cut of the film with a number
of major changes including the moment
Finn and Jana are on the deck of the
Star Destroyer trying to take out that
signal tower in the theatrical cut bb-8
Hotwire's a terminal to unlock hatch in
which Jana throws grates but according
to some anonymous possibly [ __ ]
secondary source
bb-8 was added in last minute via VFX
and in the director's cut then was going
to use the Force to unlock that hatch as
a defecting stormtrooper Finn has always
been a fascinating character to me
halfway through the rise of Skywalker he
and Jana realized that they were both
taking his kids by the first order like
Finn Jana defected after refusing to
fire on civilians and then tells her
what she felt was an instinct a feeling
he says the force brought me here
brought me to Rey and Poe Jana says you
say that as if it's real and Finn says
that wasn't sure then I am now and it's
interesting to revisit the then that
moment within on jakku in the force
awakens poe shoots down a stormtrooper
of a siphon a stormtrooper who marks
Finn's helmet with three streaks of the
blood and then notice what happens when
Finn stance
[Music]
JJ is using a Dutch angle here on the
close-up up then and then blaster fire
triggers an abrupt cut to another
disorienting angle the camerawork and
editing are similar to the aesthetic
used in war films to conveyed mid-battle
confusion in the fog of war but it's
also similar to the traumatic flashes
ray experiences throughout these films
like when she touched Luke's lightsaber
for the first time and triggered that
force nightmare and in this film when
touching the SIF dagger one could argue
that Ben's baptism by blood here is the
true force awakening of the force
awakens
that's why wielding the lightsaber in
that film was so thematically
significant for him as well I think
Ben's force sensitivity reflects the
effort by all three of these films in
the modern trilogy 2d mythologized the
force as a kind of spiritual
undercurrent disconnected from
bloodlines like the broom boy at the end
of last Jedi Finn is a force sensitive
nobody selected by the force to play a
role in the broader saga it's really a
message Disney just loves the
brainwashes with to quote one Disney
property I'm happy to be brainwashed
with not everyone can become a great
artist but a great artist can come from
anywhere this may go even deeper than
rat morals because bin selection makes
me wonder if it suggests something
deeper about the first-order in
Palpatine's secret agenda because
remember in the force awakens kylo Ren
recognized then very early on on jakku
he stops to notice been after Finn
hesitated from firing on his civilians
later when hearing the reports that they
had a defector kylo just knows it was
fn-2187 now that we know that Finn was
force sensitive during that that might
help explain kylos ability to connect
with Ben in that moment but would this
be the first moment kylo discovered
Ben's force sensitivity or had he known
about it far earlier watching the
Mandalorian in the spoiler warning for
the Mandalorian there is a plot by
surviving imperial loyalists after the
collapse of the Empire to acquire the
young lane we enrage purists by calling
baby Yoda and we still do not know what
map Gideon and Verner Herzog's client
character or dr. Pershing wanted with
baby Yoda exactly some clues appointed
to genetic engineering and cloning but
pig Nolte disagreed Mandalorian
showrunner Jon Favreau promised before
the series premiered that it would shed
some light on the origins of the
first-order and I don't know about you
but the Mandalorian season one didn't
tell me jack squat I have the first
orders origins or
it tell us jack everything could mop
Gideon's desired acquisition of baby
Yoda point to a broader conspiracy by
the surviving Palpatine loyalists in the
first order to locate force sensitive
individuals throughout the galaxy like
baby Oda like the artist subsequently
known as been to seek host bodies for
Palpatine's resurrection as he would
later try to do with Rey and for
lower-level force possessors who didn't
really make that cut to rotate those
gifted kids into stormtrooper ranks so
that they don't one day become external
threats to the first order think about
it a secret plan to systematically
require all force sensitive kids to join
the dark side that has Palpatine written
all over it
but hey comment down below with your
thoughts on this theory follow me on
instagram and twitter at EI vas and
subscribe to new rockstars to breakdowns
of everything you love thank you for
joining me and thank you for not douche
commenting before you watch this video
oh you should consider this portion
today more reserved
[Music]